avec nous ce soir le ministre de
l'économie qui a fait tiquer pas une bon
soir monsieur fils ben on se fie lyon
investissement bien différent de 2015 en
2015 fallait sauver la cseries
aujourd'hui vous miser davantage sur un
cheval qui est en croissance est-ce que
vous avez la conviction que les 300
millions américains vont rapporter de
l'argent à l'état québécois
l'acte et on a pris une décision dès le
6 mai on ne regardait le plan matériel
avec v la société il y avait un besoin
de 1.2 milliard pour se rendre jusqu'au
point marc pour faire de l'argent il ya
eu du retard à cause de pandémie et pas
de doute dont nous avions deux choix
nous pouvions inversée au point vesti on
a décidé retire parce que d'une part je
pense qu'on va pouvoir récupérer
potentiellement l'investissement
régional à 2015 du milliard qui avaient
des cerveaux verdi et d'autre part on a
des engagements de la part de airbus
pour par exemple conserver les
programmes à mirabel ne pas délocaliser
on a des engagements aussi court si
jamais on fait la 200 av ces 500 qui est
dans les cartons on peut la faire à
mirabel et on a aussi un moyen défensif
de se faire racheter en 2028 si jamais
les intentions pas de mérite sinon à 100
millions j'ai fait des ventes de se
faire acheter 300 millions
en fait une formule qui nous on peut se
faire acheter ou plus élevé de la valeur
marchande ou des montants qui seraient
résiduelles parce qu'ils répondent à de
beaux esprits ce matin si les héros
emploi on recevrait ses 3 millions ok je
pense que s'il va baisser qu'en 2000
grand pour nora une évaluation et au
soir la chine dément pas et donc je
comprends bien que le milliard qui est
investi américain en 2015 qui n'a plus
de valeur officiellement là en ce moment
vous avez je sais pas la conviction au
confiance ou vous espérer qu'on peut se
refaire ce milliard là
maintenez votre collaborateur tantôt
faisait référence 709 700 communes ou à
220 17 cents
200 vols présentement des cieux
européens et américains et 500 quand
même quand on regarde la cadence on peut
faire quatre avions global
et jusqu'à 10 samira bel 6 mai la belle
sera indices clément 2520 nous avons
montée à 3000 emplois et les croyants
fait de l'argent donc il faut
effectivement je pense qu'un avion est
le souffre et le dit pendant plusieurs
reprises le 220 c'est le deuxième mais
un programme de airbus après le 300 m
121 avions qui ont une place dans
l'échiquier mondial de l'eau dit ok on
devait dans l'entente au préalable le
rachat des actions se faisait au 1er
janvier 2026 était 2026 si je me trompe
pas là on reporte à 2028 vous ne parle
également de 2030 kantari ces échéances
là est ce que
si airbus veut racheter la part du
gouvernement du québec est ce que le
gouvernement du québec est obligé de
vendre des actions aux questions non
paiement de la transaction ont fait en
sorte en 2030 airbus vont nous lâcher et
abuse le dis clairement veut pas avoir
de gouvernement quels moyens de
fonctionner nos programmes je compte ce
qui va durer des décennies dans les
vingt ans le lieu de 300 ha vaisselier
25 un mouvement de 200 villes sauf deux
programmes peuvent avoir décroché deux
générations de scénic tôt donc le
gouverneur a besoin vouloir sortir le
gouvernement on ne négocie de repousser
la date de sortie à 2015 parce que ce
moment alors de la veille d'argent en
vertu c'est nous qui pouvons donner nos
actions et abuse il est obligé de nous
racheter sûr que moyen défensif parce
que la population à juste titre de
s'assurer qu'on met pas trouver 100
millions qui convoitait encore d'enfant
2020 et souhaitons que ce htc puis dans
l'emploi sae de repos messieurs puis
dans un trou et techniquement mur dont
300 millions dont je reste un instrument
défensif de rush qu'on peut avoir mais
honnêtement on était un de mes grands
depuis la minus l'économie en 2030 soit
en poste décideront telle valeur
marchande vont pouvoir récupérer un
milliard ça soit vous faites du québec
en 2030
retrouvez
airbus refuse de parler d'une version
allongée de la 200 rester artisans part
mais c'est pas dans l'entente
d'aujourd'hui pourquoi
pourquoi on n'est pas allés jusque là
que d'avoir cet engagement certain et
ferme la part d'airbus canada qu'on va
développer un à 220 allonge et puis ça
va profiter à mirabel
actuellement c'est pas au gouvernement
de demander à airbus de faire quoi que
ce soit nous sommes posés par contre ce
que nous avons négocié c'est que si
airbus décide de faire le 220 6 500 il
va se faire la belle dans la mesure où
on va participer au développement vous
rendre ce nouvel avion un c pour les 300
convives ont fait un nouvel avion de
voir des coûts d'opération de deux
hôpitaux alors si le gouvernement veut
participer à son engagement
comme le ior je pense que la question
c'est quoi si ça va être que ok un mot
en terminant sur les ondes d'innovation
qui ont été annoncés hier pour bromont
pour sherbrooke sherbrooke avec ibm qui
va bâtir sur un ordinateur quantique le
plus puissant au canada
il ya de l'argent beaucoup privé et il
ya de l'argent public la 157 millions on
à la description pour cette zone
d'innovation vous en voulez combien
comme ça des ondes innovation au québec
mais ce festival
en fait pour se qualifier pour une zone
d'une ovation il faut deux choses
principales il faut une thématique où on
a un secteur où de québec peut être de
gagner au niveau mondial et deuxièmement
pour de périr échoué au rendez vous
parce que programme
si seulement gouvernement qui réussit
généralement ça marche pas donc on veut
arriver il y avait une thématique
j'aimerais en avoir eu 9 ou 10 mai en
europe ou cinq ans c'est possible alors
dans le cas du coin c'est que le vivier
dit ses doigts pour devenir
d'ordinateurs canada on va avoir ne cap
dans le monde chez ibm et lorsqu'on a vu
avec la drac romantique même déjà comme
airbus qui utilise beaucoup beaucoup la
puissance de calcul pour leur donner je
pense qu'on va voir un développement
d'entreprises qui vont en garder le côté
action bromont on a laissé intelligent
de microprocesseurs enfin autre
vraiment dans l'année deux quoi vous
avez pensé les bons chiffes on
assisterait près de 10 millions des
lotissements dont 145 très bien on va
suivre avec intérêt développement des
ondes innovation merci messieurs venez
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
merci monsieur fillon pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit